Este tema hay que sacarlo del foco
mediático porque esto exige discreción.
Yo estoy con las víctimas de ETA,
este trabajo se hace fuera de los focos mediáticos
y sobre todo y ante todo
fuera de los intereses electoralistas,
porque
yo creo que hay 1 patrón que se repite
desgraciadamente
cada vez que nos acercamos a 1 momento político
importante, ETA Cobra relevancia la conversación pública
y entonces eh, por 1 lado hay 1 intento,
yo creo fuera de las cámaras,
discreto importante que se está eh
eh que está abriendo Paso y está dando
eh frutos, diría yo de
en en sentido de la construcción de la convivencia.
Y por otro lado yo observo
intereses de otro tipo
y nosotros no vamos a participar de ello,
nos negamos a participar
porque eso no es 1 ejercicio edificante
y eso eh
no está dirigido
precisamente a la reparación de las víctimas
ni a la construcción de la convivencia.
Y dicho eso quiero terminar diciendo 1 cosa,
si con esas palabras yo
eh pude herir la sensibilidad de las víctimas de ETA,
pido perdón desde aquí